- Good afternoon, everyone.
This is such a wonderful audience
and it's really quite a
thrill and an honor to be here
to welcome Anderson Cooper
as our 2023 Spring Chubb fellow.
My name is Mary Lui.
I am the Head of College
for Timothy Dwight College,
and it is truly-
(audience cheering)
Oh.
Thank you, TD!
It's always-
(audience cheering)
(Mary laughs)
- [Man] I think you packed the house.
- (laughing) We might have
tipped the scales a little bit.
(audience laughing)
So before we begin today's conversation
with Anderson Cooper,
I'm just gonna ask that all of
you turn off your cell phones
and refrain from taking any photographs
while the program is going.
I would also like to start our program
with a land acknowledgement.
Today's Chubb Fellowship event
sits on traditional
indigenous territories.
This includes lands of the Mohegan,
the Mohican, the Mashantucket
Pequot, Eastern Pequot,
Schaghticoke, Golden Hill Paugussett,
Niantic, Quinnipiac,
and other Algonquian-speaking peoples.
We honor and pay respect to their peoples
of past and present.
As I said, my name is Mary Lui.
I'm the head of College
of Timothy Dwight College.
I'm a professor in the
department of History
and the program in American Studies.
I also have the great honor
of being the custodian
of the Chubb Fellowship,
and I wanna give you a
little bit of information
and background about the
Chubb before we begin.
Established in 1941,
the Chubb Fellowship came
out of a large donation
for "education purposes",
made in 1936 by Hendon Chubb,
a graduate of the Yale class of 1895.
Since its establishment,
the Chubb Fund has adhered to the goals
of providing encouragement
and aid to students
interested in government
and American public affairs.
The fellowship initially aimed to foster,
among Yale undergraduates,
an interest in public service
and local and state affairs,
grew over the years
to include numerous distinguished visitors
in national and international affairs,
as well as leaders in the world
of the arts and humanities.
Since the 1940s,
the Chubb Fellowship lecture series
has inspired generations of Yale students
to undertake public service
and pursue leadership roles
in the hopes of creating
a better world today
and for posterity.
The fellowship has hosted
four US presidents,
George H. W. Bush, Gerald Ford,
Jimmy Carter, and Harry Truman.
In recent years,
we have welcomed a wide range of national
and international leaders,
including our congressional
representative,
the Honorable Rosa Deloro,
violin virtuoso, Hillary Hahn,
highly decorated of Olympic
figure skater, Michelle Kwan,
visual artist, Faith Ringold,
environmental activist, Bill McKibben,
Somali physician and
humanitarian, Dr. Hawa Abdi,
and so many more.
So with this quick
description of the history
and aims of the Chubb Fellowship,
I'm deeply honored to have Anderson Cooper
join the impressive list of Chubb fellows
who have visited Timothy Dwight
College in Yale's campus.
So welcome, Anderson.
(Mary, audience clapping)
And now I wanna welcome to
the stage, James, Jimmy Hatch,
to introduce Anderson
Cooper fully and properly.
Come on up.
(all clapping)
- Thanks, Mary.
Thanks, everybody, who clapped.
I don't know why you would
do that, but whatever.
I know everybody wants to hear Anderson,
so I'm gonna make this quick,
but I think it's important.
I met Anderson when he interviewed me,
I think it was 2015,
and he made quite an impact on me.
I'd seen him on television
and I'd seen him do some things
that, to me, were rather impressive
and I'll get to those in a second.
First thing I wanna do is read,
so you get to know him...
(audience laughing)
See, this is not unlike Anderson.
He fixed my tie once in an interview.
(audience laughing)
Get it together, Mary. (laughing)
So before his late mother passed,
he and she wrote this book,
and I found this part
of it really beautiful
knowing Anderson a little bit.
So I'm just gonna read her description.
To quote Elizabeth Browning,
"I love you in ways that are infinite
and as in eternity, have
no beginning or end.
But are we alike?"
And again, this is his mother speaking.
"Sometimes I think hardly at all.
You are the living image of your father,
not only in appearance,
but in valuing the same
standards he held in high regard,
standards that are
sometimes hard to live by.
Other times, yes, we are
indeed completely alike.
We share sensitivity, tempered by poise
and the reserve to reveal only
what we wish to communicate.
We have the gift of editing,
presenting ourselves
in different ways to different people.
We are not gossips.
We are worthy to be trusted
with secrets of family and friends.
We have fun going to the movies together,
sharing a bag of popcorn.
We do not burden each
other with trivial troubles
or pull each other down
with unsupportive comments.
We advise each other on pressing
matters from time to time.
And you always give me a short, sensible,
well-thought-out solution to any problem.
I try to respond in the same manner.
We both spend a lot of
time organizing our lives,
secretly working out various
options and scenarios
in our heads.
Luckily, yours are far more practical
and more likely to
become reality than mine,
which continue to be influenced
by the enchanted fairy
tales I read as a child.
In spite of this,
I treasure those fairy tales
for they are, in large part,
what spur my creativity.
We share a restless spirit.
In fact, we are never at rest.
And rarely, if ever, will
anything satisfy Andy and his mom.
Soon something beckons.
It's there around the
corner, just out of sight.
All we need to do is follow.
All my life, I have
craved and long for love,
and I have not been deprived.
My cup has runneth over,
but it was never enough.
It never got anywhere near
what the trouble really was.
No mother, no father,
as my secret sister, Susan
Sontag, knew too well.
Here, Andy, thankfully, we are not alike.
Even though you lost your
father when you were 10,
you knew that there
wasn't a moment from birth
when you didn't have and know his support,
how fully completely he
loved you and Carter.
Although only those years were given,
they were enough for him to pass on to you
the values that have made
you the person that you are,
my son, treasured each moment of my life."
I don't think you can get
much better than that.
Now, as for me personally,
I remember watching,
I was in the SEAL Teams
and in the SEAL Teams,
people like Anderson, journalists,
are essentially the same
as any other enemy we have. (chuckles)
So I was rather-
(audience laughing)
I was rather harsh on journalists.
But I remember watching.
It was in the early nineties,
and I've discussed this
with one of Anderson's camera guys, Neil.
They were in Haiti and there
were some troubles there.
Often there are troubles in Haiti.
But Anderson was standing
at an intersection.
He was on camera.
I was watching him,
and I think I was actually
overseas somewhere
when I was watching it.
And he's talking
and all of a sudden you can see
in the buildings behind him,
rocks and other projectiles hitting them.
And it was getting ugly quick.
And Anderson immediately
turned and grabbed this kid,
threw him under his arm
and started running
outta the intersection.
And I thought to myself, man,
that's something you're
either born with or not.
You can't train somebody to do that,
to be that thoughtful
in the middle of emergency
situation like that,
to grab someone who can't be protected
and get 'em outta there.
So he became less of an enemy
at that point to me. (chuckles)
And then I was in New York
after Anderson and I had gotten
to be a little bit closer.
I was in New York for another function,
and I went to the CNN Studios
and it happened to be the same time
that the Pulse Nightclub
shooting had gone down.
So Anderson was in Orlando.
And I was in the production room.
It's really cool to see
how the sausage is made,
so to speak, how busy people are.
And Anderson was down there
and he was reporting on the shooting.
And then they went to a commercial.
And during the commercial,
Anderson had a long piece of paper
and he was reading off names.
And there was one of the
producers in the booth
was helping him so that he
could say the names properly.
And some of 'em were tough
and it was so emotional
and Anderson was emotional.
But his drive to be respectful
and to make sure that
everybody who lost their life
was acknowledged and done
so in a respectful way.
And the way he did that,
in that short chunk of time,
and earnestly showed me who he was.
And then when he read their names,
he became, he's human.
He's not a robot.
And I was taken by that.
The thing that is the most
important about Anderson to me,
and it's something that
is really important
that I've learned here
at Yale in my short time
and through my time in the military.
We are in a time when it's
easy to dehumanize one another.
And Anderson interviews
a lot of different people
and is in a lot of different situations.
And I've never ever seen him,
even though he might disagree,
I've never seen him
dehumanize another person.
And I think that's a super
important thing right now.
And I think it's an example for all of us.
And with that, I'll shut up
and let 'em get after it.
(audience clapping)
- I realize in my excitement
to just get going with
the conversation with you,
I didn't properly introduce you, Jimmy,
and I really apologize.
So I'm gonna say-
(Jimmy murmurs)
No, no, I'm gonna do it because you know,
Anderson won't forgive me if I don't.
So who you just heard from
is a wonderful member
of our Timothy Dwight College community.
This is James, Jimmy
Hatch, third year student.
He's part of the Eli Whitney Program.
He's also the founder
of the Spikes K9 Fund,
which advocates for the US
working canine population.
So he's done incredible work there
and cannot thank you
enough for all you do.
So, okay, with that,
I think we can segue.
- Hello.
- Hello. (laughing)
- Reading the list of names of people
who've done this before,
I feel like I've really
brought the gradient down.
(audience laughing)
I feel like you guys were
desperate or something, but-
(audience laughing)
I appreciate being here though.
And thank you all for coming.
- Um, no...
(audience laughing)
We were very thoughtful.
There were many other people.
- You shouldn't start
off with US presidents.
That's-
(audience laughing)
It's a little intimidating,
I gotta say. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Oh, I don't know.
- Especially, Truman.
Like, wow, okay.
Did he like sit here?
Was he here?
- No.
- Okay.
- No. No.
That would be the wrong timeline.
- Yeah, I know.
- But that's okay.
So I would say, as we were
joking before on our way here,
that for me preparing for
this conversation with you
was a little bit like cramming for an exam
where I was madly reading
and rereading works of yours.
- Right, ChatGPT will take care of that.
Don't worry.
(Mary and audience laughs)
- Ah!
(Anderson laughs)
The TD community knows
a little bit too much
about me and ChatGBT,
but that's another story.
But in all seriousness,
looking at all the things
you have accomplished
and here you are with your
CNN badge right out here,
along with the publication
starting with "Dispatches from the Edge,"
and that was back in 2005, I wanna say.
- Yeah.
- 2006?
- Probably 2006, I'm thinking.
Yeah, that's my first book I wrote.
- Yeah and then "Vanderbilt:
The Rise and Fall of an
American Dynasty," 2021.
- Yes.
- There's a lot in between.
I don't quite understand
how you have the time
to do all of that while being on CNN,
while being on 60 Minutes
and then doing all the
things that you've done.
So I'm curious to hear
how you see your writing projects
that you've done along the way.
If you don't mind.
- Sure.
- I would actually like to start there.
- Yeah.
- And has there been a pathway,
a vision of what you would be, yeah.
- So yeah, so I've written,
well three, I'm writing a fourth book now.
My first book, "Dispatches From the Edge,"
was a book I'd been writing in my head
for probably 10 years.
I wrote it in 2006.
I got offered the opportunity to write it
during the Hurricane Katrina coverage,
which is when, I guess,
some people started to
notice me more a little bit.
And so, actually, a kid I
went to high school with
who turned out to be a literary agent,
actually a kid I went to
like elementary school with
and have known my entire life,
who used to be in a heavy metal band
and I'd lost touch with him.
He called me up and he turns
out he's a literary agent now.
Like how did that happen?
(Mary laughs)
But yeah, he became my literary agent
and I wrote this book.
And I'd been writing this book
in my head for a long time.
My brother, Carter, died by suicide
right before my senior year at Yale.
So my senior year was kind of a blur here.
I took a year off after college
and I became very interested in sort of,
and also my dad died when I was 10,
as my mom referenced in Jimmy's reading.
So I was always very
interested in sort of survival
and how, why two people
growing up in a house,
why does one person survive
and the other person doesn't,
the same kind of, we were
the same kind of people.
What happened?
And that always expanded
to sort of societies.
I was interested in societies
that had fallen apart,
whether it's through war
or political situations
or whatever it may be.
And so, as a child, I
used to read a lot about,
I was fascinated by like Zaire,
which was at that time,
run by President Mobutu.
So I would read a lot about that.
I was fascinated with like
British colonial wars.
I was like, what the
hell was that all about?
Like these British people marching along,
attacking the Zulus.
And so, I was fascinated in
sort of places on the planet
that I wanted to go to.
And I came up with this
idea after college to,
ultimately, I ended up having a friend
make a fake press pass.
I borrowed a camera.
I just started going into wars.
But I was very much driven by this idea
of loss and survival.
And so, even if I didn't really
plan on becoming a reporter,
I just, I wanted to go places
where the language of loss was spoken
and where people don't talk about grief
and loss here very much.
And I certainly didn't.
I found it very hard to talk about,
but I wanted to immerse myself in places
where people were suffering
and where people did speak about this
and I wanted to understand it.
And I found, when I got to some places,
I found an odd
ability to operate in these environments.
And I felt, in fact, easier in some ways,
not easier, but in some ways,
it was comfortable for me
to be in some environments
moreso than like being back home.
So yeah, so that book was
really a book about death
and loss and survival.
And so, it was sort of set
against the backdrop of 2005,
which had Hurricane Katrina
and the tsunami and all sorts of stories.
There was a lot of stories
I covered that year
and they all centered
around death and loss.
So it was sort of the twin stories
of what happened to my brother
and also all these places
I was along the way, yeah.
And then I wrote a book with my mom.
Like I didn't write again
for like 10 years later,
10 more years or so, 'cause
I had nothing to say.
And then my mom turned 91
and she sent me this
really kind of interesting,
odd, cool email, as she often did.
And it was all about how she still felt 17
and something her grandmother
had said to her when she was 17.
Anyway, I decided we should
have a conversation for a year
'cause like when you have a parent,
often you just know them as your parent.
You don't really know them
as a person or as a friend.
And so, I knew my mom
extraordinarily well,
but there were still all these things
I kind of didn't understand about her.
And there's a lot I
don't know about my dad
and I thought, my mom's
91, I don't want her to die
and there would be anything
left unsaid between us
and I don't want there
to be any questions.
So if we had a conscious
conversation for a year.
I sound like Gwyneth Paltrow,
like conscious uncoupling.
(audience laughing)
We had a conscious
conversation for a year,
mostly over email because
I was traveling and stuff
where she would ask me questions,
I would ask her questions
and we'd just go back and forth
and it was this amazing conversation
that I didn't intend to write as a book.
But about halfway through,
I was like, you know what?
Actually I think we could
kind of make this into a book.
And yeah, so that was that.
And then the Vanderbilt was
this book I wrote two years ago.
It was the first time I had a co-writer,
a historian, Katherine Howe,
who did most of the research.
And I didn't really know anything
about the Vanderbilt family.
I mean, my mom was Gloria Vanderbilt,
but she always thought of
herself as like a changeling.
She thought she was sort of
an imposter in that family
and wasn't really part of that family
based on some crazy stuff
that happened to her as a kid.
And so, I grew up not really
knowing anything about them an
and I consciously didn't
really want to know
anything about them.
You know, when I got to
Yale, everyone was like,
oh, are you staying in
the Vanderbilt room?
And I was like, A, that's
not really a thing.
And B, I wouldn't even if I could,
'cause I really want
nothing to do with them.
But then once I had kids,
I suddenly realized,
well, what am I gonna tell my kids
about this kind of weird thing
that happened in the past
that I'm related to apparently.
And so, yeah, so I started doing research
and decided to write that book.
- You know, it's funny until you said,
"I had nothing to say for 10 years,"
it almost, I think again, when you do all,
you read everything all at the same time,
it feels like there hasn't been that gap
because in the first
book, the Dispatches book-
- I'm basically regurgitating
the same stuff, yeah.
I'm just waiting for
enough people to die off,
they don't realize-
(audience laughing)
Oh, it's the same book again. (chuckles)
- No, I don't think so.
(all laughing)
But I think looking at Dispatch,
what was really incredible,
was hearing your voice
and talking about the things in your life
that had been really with you and sort of-
- Yeah.
- But you hadn't really explored.
- While taking us through the
insane year, that was 2005,
beginning with the 2004 tsunami.
- Yeah.
- So you're reading,
you're going back and forth
between your coverage,
dealing with so much death and destruction
and really feeling that
incredible responsibility
to every single person you're meeting.
- Right.
- To tell the story,
do more than bear witness.
I mean, you describe it so powerfully
as people are hoping you're
gonna make a difference,
by them talking to you.
- Yeah.
- While at the same time,
you're talking through your own efforts
to really talk about
the pain and suffering
you've personally gone through.
- Right.
- So then you go from that to, I think,
the book with your,
the conscious conversation
with your mother.
It seems as though,
and you never stopped
having that conversation,
I guess, is what I'm saying.
- Yeah, I mean,
yeah, those are all things I
still think about all the time.
I mean, I think for anybody
who lost a parent in this room
early on as a child,
anybody, if you lose a parent early on,
it changes the trajectory of your life.
And I certainly wasn't
able to talk about it,
the death my dad, it was so overwhelming,
it was so stunning to me.
And even now,
my voice shakes a little
bit when I think about it.
And so, I like talking about it now,
but that was something
I just didn't speak of.
And so, going to places where
people did speak about loss
because they were in the midst of a loss,
they had just experienced
the loss of a child
or a loss of their family
or an entire village wiped
out or whatever it was,
I couldn't help but,
I mean, I probably could
have just gone to therapy
and that would've probably
made a little more sense early on.
But it was an extraordinary, I mean,
both as something that
I cared very much about,
bearing witness to what
is happening in the world
and bearing witness to
the suffering of others
and the pain that others feel.
And also, yeah, I mean,
I couldn't help but feel
a commonality in some sense.
- Yeah, it seemed as one is working
our way through that book,
we land in New Orleans
in terms of Hurricane Katrina.
You're telling us again and again,
how shocking the whole
experience was for you
in terms of it being here
in the United States.
So I'm curious, prior to that,
was most of your career out in the world?
- Yeah, most everything
I did was overseas.
I really, I felt like there's
a lot of reporters in America
and like I'm like the guy
with a fake press pass
and a camera.
Why am I gonna try to compete
with somebody at the
White House reporting?
So yeah, my first story,
I snuck into Myanmar, Burma,
I hooked up with some students
fighting the Burmese government
and I shot a story about them.
I then ended up enrolling
in school in Hanoi
in the last six months of the US embargo
'cause I wanted to be someplace
where there weren't many Americans
'cause I thought that'd be
an interesting experience.
So there were very small
number of Americans
in Hanoi at the time.
Like, I think maybe 20 or so.
And yeah, so I studied
Vietnamese for a while
and I shot five stories
and then I still didn't get a job
but I was airing these things
on a thing called Channel One,
which was a show seen in
about half the high schools
and middle schools in America
in the early nineties.
If you know, you know and if you don't,
like you think it's ridiculous,
but it had this huge audience
of kids and teachers.
Nobody knew about it,
but I was a fact checker
there for like six months.
Then that's when I came up with the idea
of just going to wars
and that's what I did.
And so, they would like air the stuff,
but they still didn't hire me.
And then, I'd left high school early
and I'd ridden in a truck
across Sub-Saharan Africa for six months.
So I was still sort of
familiar with Eastern Africa.
And so, I pitched,
okay, I'm gonna go to 10 countries
over the next three months
and I'm gonna shoot 10 stories
and these are the stories
I think I'm gonna be able to shoot.
And the first one was Somalia
in the early days of the
famine in August of '92
before the US got involved,
before "Black Hawk Down,"
if you've seen that movie.
It was about a year before that,
or eight months before that.
And yeah, and Somalia,
it had a big impact on
the Channel One audience.
A lot of people started
raising money for it and stuff.
And then they hired me full-time
as like their war person,
foreign correspondent.
So yeah, Bosnia and the
Civil War, Sarajevo,
briefly in Rwanda during the genocide,
South Africa, a lot,
for the run up to and the years before
and the election of Mandela.
Soviet Georgia, wherever
there was fighting,
I mean, I would sort of go, Columbia,
Haiti for when the US
invaded after Raoul Cedras.
I was very interested in conflict
and I wanted to see,
I wanted to experience and document
what people were going through.
- Yeah, for you, is there a big difference
between documenting something
like an environmental disaster
like a hurricane or a tsunami versus war?
- I mean, logistically,
there's some differences
in terms of, obviously,
safety and security.
There are differences,
which by the way, when I started,
nobody cared about my safety
or security other than me.
So like, it wasn't like there was,
I didn't have like a
news network behind me,
so I was just out there by
myself doing really stupid stuff.
So I'm not encouraging
other people to do that
because there was a kid named Dan Eldon
who was doing the exact same thing I was
and he was hacked to
death by a mob in Somalia,
and others.
But no, I think,
I mean, obviously,
everything is different.
I try not to compare one thing to another
'cause I don't think there should be
like a sliding scale of sorrow.
And I think you need to see
everything with fresh eyes.
You need to see everything
as if it's the first time you're seeing it
because if you're so jaded,
at a certain point,
it's very easy to like start to compare
one thing to another.
Like, oh, it's not as
bad as this place was,
you know, 10 years ago.
And if you start to do that,
you're not seeing it as you should see it.
And that's a real risk that can happen.
I found myself in Rwanda
right after the elections with Mandela.
I went to Rwanda
and it's a country I'd
been in a number of times
as a teenager, in happier times.
And I was with the RPF,
the Rwanda Patriotic Front,
and went to some villages where
people had been slaughtered.
And I took a photograph
and by this point, I'd been
doing this for about three years
and I took a photograph
with my own personal camera
of five people who were
laying on the side of the road
who had decomposed on the side of a road.
And I was very interested in that moment
in how the skin on this person's hand
had peeled off like a glove.
And I took a photograph of it
and there was another reporter,
a photojournalist who I'd linked up with
who were sort of traveling
'cause I had access to a vehicle
and he hitched a ride with us.
He took a photograph of me doing that
and he sent it to me later.
And he said, this is for
when you become famous.
And he said something else to me.
And what he was saying to me was,
you've gone too far.
And I actually have that picture
up on my bulletin board at work
'cause it was a real, for me,
it was a realization that
I was no longer seeing those five people,
I believe they were family.
I was no longer seeing them as a daughter
and a mother and a father
and probably, a son.
I was interested in how
the skin was peeling off somebody's hand.
And so I stopped for quite a while
doing that sort of work
because I didn't want to forget,
like, I didn't want to see it like that.
I wanted to see it and be horrified by it
and not interested in the sort
of the things that happen.
So yeah, I think that's an
important thing to keep in mind.
For me, that's a really
important thing, to not,
you run across reporters sometimes
who are very sort of jaded
and they've been around the world
and they've been doing it for years
and you're not doing justice to the people
you're there to report on,
if you can't,
if you're not horrified by things
and if you're not stunned by things.
At least for me, I think, I can't do that.
- Yeah, and you talk a lot about trying to
keep that line and make
sure that your doing
your due dilligence as
a reporter in terms of
Forcing us to see the things
that we might not wanna see,
but yet at the same time,
I think as Jimmy so eloquently
said, never dehumanizing.
So it's not easy to do
and I really applaud you for doing that.
And I'm just curious,
how do you manage to feel like
you never lose sight of that line?
- I don't know.
I mean, I hope I don't.
I mean, I try to be very conscious of it.
I'm very interested in,
I'm sort of awkward around human beings.
I'm very shy and introverted,
but when I'm working,
I'm very engaged with somebody.
And it's sort of the only
time I can really engage
and really focus on somebody.
And not the only time, I
mean, I'm not that weird.
(Mary, audience laughing)
But I do think it's,
yeah, I don't know.
I don't really know how
to answer that question.
I mean, I think it's
important to not lose sight
of the fact that these
are all human beings
involved in things.
When we're covering politicians
who are saying awful,
stupid, ridiculous things,
it's interesting,
it's easy to not think of
somebody as a human being.
It's easy to just think of them as,
in Rwanda during, in the
run up to the genocide,
on the Rwandan radio,
they would call Tutsi's cockroaches.
And the whole idea is to dehumanize people
so that you can then take the next step
and do things to them.
So even people you don't like,
I think it's important to view
them as flawed human beings
and try to see, walk in their shoes
and see where they're coming from
and understand why they're
making the arguments
they're making,
what forces are at play in their world
and in their work life.
But just on the day to
day coverage of things,
there was an active shooter
today in Louisville.
You know, I have a policy,
I don't show active shooters,
I don't name them.
History has recorded these people's names.
And I don't think anybody in this room
can name somebody who died at Columbine.
Maybe somebody could,
but you could probably name
the killers at Columbine
much more than you can
name any of the people
who were killed.
And I think that goes
for many of the active
shooting situations.
So yeah, I just, I have a policy.
I don't show their pictures.
I report on them.
I report on motivations.
I report on whatever
needs to be reported on,
but I try to always focus
on naming the people
who have been killed,
naming those whose lives were lost.
And that's, I mean,
it's a small thing in the
grand scale of things,
but it does sort of,
it is a guidepost for the way
I view a lot of things I report on.
- You're clearly very busy.
There's no lack of news in the world
and today's shooting is
only one of many things
that keep happening.
It must be really difficult
to be able to make the
decision of what gets aired,
what gets put on in
the time that you have.
- Yeah, I mean there's a certain,
because I'm not motivated
by ideology and coverage,
so in some ways it's not that difficult
because things which are happening,
my focus is what has
happened today or what is,
what's in the news today
or what's an important story?
And some of it is tempered
by where do we have correspondence,
where are our people,
what stories do we have ready to go?
What guests can we get?
So some of the coverage is based on that.
But you know, for me, it's not,
for me, it's based on what's
happened today usually
often takes precedence.
But if it's obviously an ongoing story,
it's what the latest thing on that is,
rather than, if you're
ideologically motivated
and you have a channel
which is geared toward
spreading election lies,
then your coverage can be based on,
it doesn't need to be based on anything
that's happened on that particular day.
It can be just driving toward that.
And that doesn't interest me.
- Have you ever had to really
push for airtime of something?
- Yeah, certainly.
Look, it's always a discussion.
I have an executive producer
who I've worked with
for 20-something years at CNN.
He and I have been together
in a lot of really dangerous places
and he puts up with me.
And so, I'm lucky to work with him.
And so, we know each other very well,
but he and I have,
I mean, it's an ongoing
discussion all day long.
We have a conference call in the morning.
All throughout the day,
we're figuring out,
okay, everything we think
we're gonna do in the morning
that we think will be on the evening show.
I have a show that's
on from eight to nine.
A lot of, 70% of that might
not make it on by the time.
And the show we have ready
to go at 7:59 and 59 seconds,
the second before we go on air,
that can all be tossed
out the moment we go on
and I learn something else happened.
So the story in Tennessee
on the lawmakers,
the three lawmakers who were voted,
two of them were expelled.
You know, that started
breaking just 20 minutes
or so before the eight o'clock show began.
And that was not what we had planned to do
most of the show on,
but we ended up, I think,
doing the first 30 minutes just live.
We had cameras in the hallway.
We had interviews with
one of the lawmakers
just after he was voted out.
We were following the
vote as it was going on.
We were able to pull in
interesting guests on it.
So it's a combination of
factors that kind of go into it.
- So you're taking the day off today?
- I am, yes.
Yes, it's a rare time that
I take the day off, yeah.
Yes, it's sort of like
in the Charlie Brown
like in the Charlie Brown spelling bee,
when you spell a word wrong,
it's like, (playfully murmuring).
And then they just go like (lips puckers),
you just disappear.
(Mary laughs)
So I feel like if I disappear
too long from the screen
that someone else will just replace me
who's much smarter and better, so.
(audience laughing)
- So for one day, it's okay.
- One day, it's okay.
- Yes, yeah.
- Right.
- So you won't have to
disappear at eight o'clock
to go do your show?
- We'll see, we'll see what happens.
Lemme see what time it is now.
Oh, we got plenty of time.
(Mary laughs)
- So yeah, I did wanna-
- I could, like honestly,
worst case scenario, it's 4:42.
Like if I needed to,
I could do a show from here
probably at eight if I had to.
- You could do it from dinner.
- (chuckles) Well, yeah.
I'd probably have to
go off to a side thing.
But yeah, we've done
shows in some weird areas.
- Okay, we will keep that in mind.
- Okay.
- What's the biggest
change for you as an anchor
versus being out there
traveling the world and-
- You know, the nice,
I mean, it's such a
ridiculous term, anchor.
I started out, as I said, just overseas
and so for the first,
certainly three years,
I was just this person
with a small camera,
I started getting like one producer
or two producers from Channel One.
And we would all travel
together and we'd all shoot,
but it didn't seem to be going anywhere.
It wasn't like, I didn't
think, I wasn't planning,
like this is my pathway to
finally getting that anchor job
I've always dreamed of.
To me, the vision of an
anchor was like Kent Brockman
on The Simpsons.
(Mary laughs)
So that I wasn't really aiming for that.
And he is sort of an accurate
representation of some folks.
Then literally,
Newsweek, there used to be a
magazine called Newsweek that-
(audience laughing)
Did an article about Channel One
and they wrote about some
of the stuff I had done
'cause it was like this weird kid
who shows up in these places
and he shoots these stories
and ABC read that and asked for a tape
and I thought they were kidding.
I thought it was like a joke
that somebody was calling.
And anyway, I learned it wasn't.
I put together a tape.
And so, they hired me as a correspondent,
which was insane 'cause I was 27.
And in those days, they didn't
hire anybody in that age.
But I never really wanted to,
like anchoring just seemed
not like something I was
pretty interested in.
But I started anchoring on the evening
on a overnight newscast.
But the nice thing about CNN is you still,
they still want you out in the field.
They still want you going to,
anchoring just gives you a
little bit more the ability
to frankly choose where you go.
So my day is much more
determined by myself
than it would be if I,
if I was a correspondent
waking up every day,
I might get sent someplace.
And I knew one day, I wanted to have kids
and I wanted to be able to
at least have some agency
over my schedule.
But it's nice because you can,
your question earlier about
can you argue about where,
you know, I can insist on going.
I did a whole week in DRC Congo,
which used to be Zaire,
which I was obsessed with as a kid
and I'm still fascinated by DRC Congo.
So I go there a lot
and I did a whole week
of shows from there,
which was not necessarily where
a news network is probably gonna
want to send you for a week
'cause it's very expensive
and difficult to work there.
But they knew it was an important story
that I was wanting to do
and I was doing something
story about sexual violence
on Eastern Congo and
they supported me on it.
So you're able to get stuff on the air
that you might otherwise not,
if you have, maybe if you're an anchor
'cause you have your own show.
You can kind of determine that.
- So I think I'm starting
to see a little bit
of how you're able to write books
'cause you're able to control
your time a little bit more,
in that sense.
- I also, I mean, until I've
had kids, I've had no life.
So like, I don't know,
like you may think like I've
had some like glamorous fun.
Like this is all I've been doing.
Like I haven't been out there
like enjoying myself like in you know,
my entire twenties,
all my friends were like having dinners
and going out to clubs and stuff
and I lost all my friends
'cause I was always away
and they like, I'd
constantly cancel any meetup
or dinner or whatever I had with 'em
because if something would
happen, then I would just be off.
And so, after a while people are like,
oh, why even call this guy?
So it made it much easier for me-
- So you're that friend?
- I'm that friend.
So it made it much easier
just focus on work.
And so, I've really,
and I've loved it 'cause the work has been
the most exciting thing
I could possibly imagine.
Everything else pales in comparison.
I mean, there's nothing more
extraordinary in my mind than,
you know, something happens in the world
and I can get on a plane
and I can actually go to wherever.
I can go to Ukraine
and within a 24-hour period
or however long it takes to get there,
I can be in a tank moving
toward a front line
with Ukrainian soldiers or I can be,
and that's an extraordinary thing,
to be able to drop into
other people's lives
and in the most,
and it's not just visiting
other people's lives.
It's dropping in, in people's
lives in the most intense,
sometimes horrific but or
exciting or whatever it is,
most important moment
of their life, often.
Or often where their
life is under a threat.
And to be able to tell their story
and allowed to tell their story by them
and to kind of be able
to try to do justice
to the sights and the
sounds and the smells of it
and bring that, and send
that and package that
and write it in a way that is accurate,
to me, why wouldn't I
do that all the time?
It's incredible.
I cannot believe I get to do it.
- So you describe that
and you've written a book
that is more of a history work.
- Yes.
- Vanderbilt,
which the research process can't be
as exciting and glamorous
as what you just described.
I assume it's a lot of pouring over.
That's my my world.
- Well, as I said, this is
the first book I co-wrote,
so Katherine Howe, who is a
great historian and writer,
she did most of the legwork on it,
so I cannot claim to have,
I benefited from the arduous
hours that she put in.
But I certainly read
extensively history books
but for me, what was interesting about
trying to write a history book
and particularly on the Vanderbilts is,
look, there have been
Pulitzer prize winning books
about Commodore Vanderbilt,
who was my great, great, great or great,
three or four greats, grandfather,
who was not a nice person.
I mean he was probably,
he had a self-described mania for money.
He very well could have been a psychopath.
There're a lot more psychopaths out there
than I think we all realize
in the world of business
and maybe media as well.
But I wanted to, to me
what was interesting is not
to try to write a linear history
'cause there's no way I
would write something as good
as has already been written out there,
but was to kind of drop in moments
in these historical figures lives
and kind of see them as humans
and see them sort of how the money,
the ripple effects of the,
you have this patriarch of a family
who is obsessed with money
and has a mania for money.
And from the age of 11 and builds,
by the year Commodore
Vanderbilt died in 1877,
one out of every $15,
one outta every $20 in
circulation belonged to him.
So he died with a hundred million dollars,
which today is not,
people, you think, well,
Bezos's boat cost 500 million,
but a hundred million dollars back then,
I mean, it was an extraordinary figure.
He had more money than
the US Treasury had.
And his son doubled that
fortune in eight years,
which is incredible.
And what's even more incredible
is that the third and fourth generation
went on a spending spree,
the likes of which you cannot believe.
And unlike the Astors, who
I'm writing a book about now,
they didn't reinvest it
in like the land that became New York.
They built these ginormous palaces
and gave Vanderbilt Hall.
(Mary, audience laughing)
They built these enormous palaces
that were torn down within 60 years
because they were so bloated
and needed 60 servants to run them
and tax laws changed and
inheritance taxes changed.
And no one wanted to live in these houses.
And they were sold off for scrap.
And to me that's
fascinating, the arc of that.
You know, it's always
interesting 'cause you know,
I come from this family
and for my entire life everybody assumed
that I was like the Scion
of the Vanderbilt family
and would be inheriting great
wealth from the Vanderbilts,
like as if there was some sort of
giant Vanderbilt slush fund
that I was just about to be
immersed in at age of 21.
And both my parents,
like my dad took me to see the
Commodore Vanderbilt statue,
which is outside Grand
Central Station in New York
as he founded Grand Central Station
and he owned the 16 acres of
midtown Manhattan at the time.
Don't know what happened to that.
(Mary, audience laughing)
But my dad took me,
my dad who grew up very
poor Mississippi on a farm,
and took me to see this
statue when was like,
I don't know, 12 or something or maybe 10.
And to explain to me
that this is like my
great-great great grandfather.
And the only thing I
came away understanding
is that all grandparents turned
into statues when they died.
So I must have been-
(Mary, audience laughing)
Like six actually at the time.
But what he was showing me
was to then to let me know
that as I grew older,
I would hear more about this family
that my mom had belonged to.
But that to not buy into it,
to not believe that there was some
like a pot of gold waiting
for me 'cause there wasn't,
there was no trust fund,
there was no nothing like that.
And I'm very lucky
that, that was the case.
'Cause you look at the
history of the Vanderbilts,
all of whom inherited great fortunes,
a lot of 'em didn't do
much with their lives.
They spent a lot of money.
In fact, one of them said that
inheriting money equals like,
I've forgotten his quote,
but it's like, it's as bad as cocaine
because like you think
it's gonna last forever
and it feels great and you do nothing.
And that's really, to me,
sort of why I wanted to
write this book, for my kids,
'cause I don't want them to feel
like that there's some pot
of gold waiting for them
because there's not.
- It's just a giant cautionary tale.
- It's a giant cautionary tale, yes.
I think, I'm fascinated by this whole,
like all these people who we all look to,
people, not the People Magazine,
you look at people on the
cover of People Magazine
and all these people we read about
and look at on social media
and we think, wow, it's incredible.
I view them as like deeply warped
and in need of serious help.
Like-
(Mary, audience laughing)
I mean, I'm fascinated that we all are
like brought up to look at these people
and think like, oh my God, if only,
and like when you actually
look at their lives,
the misery of, Commodore Vanderbilt,
he sent his wife to an insane asylum
so he could (indistinct) the babysitter.
(Mary, audience laughing)
It's true.
(audience laughing)
- So I was gonna say,
with so many people that
you could have chosen to,
I mean obviously,
your statue ancestor
has to be in the story
'cause he's the star of the whole thing.
- Yes.
- But once you get past him,
there's so many people you
could have lingered on.
So I'm curious if there were people that,
if you had more chapters,
who would you have added
back into the book?
- You know, actually-
- You're good?
- Yeah, I'm good.
Like, I enjoyed spending time with them,
but at a certain point,
I'm like I didn't wanna spend
any more time with them.
Like I'm writing this
book about the Astors now
and there's a lot of dreadful Astors.
I mean, they're just sort of dreadful
and after a while,
you just don't wanna spend
any more time with them.
They make the Vanderbilts
seem, I don't know,
more fun. (laughing)
(Mary, audience laughing)
Yeah.
- Well, you describe the feud that went on
between Caroline Astor and-
- Alva Vanderbilt?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
Yeah, so basically, I
mean it's, I don't know.
- It puts like the Jersey Shore
Housewives show to whatever.
- Yes, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, there was this epic feud.
It's too long and involved to go into.
I can't even, yeah.
- Yeah.
- We'll have to talk about it off camera.
- Okay.
- So much there.
But no, I'm really-
- I can tell you're a
historian 'cause this-
- I know, I was just like
loving every single moment.
You have such a beautiful way of,
you and Katherine Howe,
have such a beautiful way
of rendering the past.
And so much of this history
I'm very familiar with,
but I really, I felt like I
was there at these crazy balls.
- Yeah, it's nice
'cause there was a lot
of first person accounts
with the Vanderbilts.
With the Astros, actually not so much.
So it's actually, it's tricky.
But yeah, the Astros actually
destroy their records
pretty much every generation,
which is interesting.
- Hmm.
- Yeah, so.
- Yep and then poor Consuelo
being locked into her room.
- Yes.
- Before her wedding.
- Yeah.
- All those things.
- Right, 'cause Consuelo Vanderbilt
was like married off to,
the Vanderbilts, they had
money, but they had no,
they didn't have entree
in New York society.
So back then, they had so much money that,
that seemed important to them to,
to like get into New York society.
And one of the ways was to
start marrying off people
to British nobility.
So they would get a British title
and all the British nobility
were all like counts of no account,
as my grandmother used to say.
(Mary, audience laughing)
Meaning they had the title
but they had no money.
So it was this perfect match
of like Nouveau riches,
ridiculously wealthy, tacky New Yorkers
marrying the Duke of Marlboro.
And they get married and
misery ensues for generations.
(Mary, audience laughing)
It's true.
They're all miserable, yeah.
- Yeah, they do not look happy.
- No, they're miserable.
- No, no.
- Yeah.
- Well, so, when is the
Astro book gonna come out?
- I think in September.
- Oh wow, so you're almost there.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yes, I'm doing edits right now.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Well, maybe we'll have
you back when it's over.
- Okay. Sure.
- But you have another
project that's going
and that's been really
different, the podcast.
- Yes, that's what the world
needs, another podcast.
Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Maybe not, but your
podcast is really special.
- My podcast is special.
- Your podcast is special.
- That is true.
Thank you for saying that.
Yeah. (laughing)
So yeah.
I had no interest in doing a podcast.
I did not think the world
needs another podcast.
And yet, here I am.
I did an eight season,
eight episode podcast
about grief and loss.
And I found, my mom died three years ago
and yeah, 2019,
and almost four years ago.
And while going through her stuff,
which is this process,
everybody who has lost
somebody goes through,
I found it incredibly
lonely and isolating.
And in going through her stuff,
my mom was like a very fancy hoarder.
There was a lot of stuff
and it was also my father's stuff
and my brother's stuff
'cause all of that had
just been packed away
and nobody had ever gone through it.
So I'm the last surviving member
of the little family that I was born into.
And so, I was going through
a storage room full of boxes
and it was like the storage room in,
I dunno if you remember the closing scene
of "Raiders of the Lost Ark,"
where there's like all just,
the ark is stored in
this warehouse of boxes.
And I like that nobody below the age of 25
is nodding their head
'cause they haven't even seen that movie.
(Mary, audience laughing)
But...
So I just found it incredibly isolating
and I started, I'm a
big, I like this book,
Viktor Frankl's, "Man's
Search for Meaning,"
and one of the things
Viktor Frankl writes about
is he's a psychologist
who was in Auschwitz.
He talks about narrating experiences,
horrible experiences in his head
as a way of going through them.
And so, he narrates them as he would
sort of a professor narrating
a clinical situation.
And I found myself narrating,
as I'm going through all these boxes,
as I would a correspondent
if I was like writing this story,
I was sort of narrating
in my head this stuff.
And I just started recording it
and ended up putting this
together with some interviews
with some people who
discussed loss and grief
in ways that blew my mind.
And one of them was Stephen Colbert,
whose father and two younger brothers
were killed in an Eastern
Airlines plane crash
when Stephen was 10-years-old.
And Stephen talks about grief in a way
that I've never heard before.
And I'd done a brief interview
with him years ago about it.
And so, he's in the podcast
and it's all these people,
it's Lori Anderson, who's
a really cool musician,
Elizabeth Alexander, who was here at Yale.
So it's just different ways of
thinking about grief and loss
and it's, yeah,
I've been surprised at the response to it.
It's been pretty extraordinary.
- I think, probably,
especially in this moment in time
when we're coming outta Covid,
I mean, obviously, as you've said,
death is something that we all go through,
having to survive it,
deal with the aftermath.
But I think we're in a place,
maybe in American society and the world
that has been dealing with so much death
and maybe your podcast is coming along
at a time that we all need it
to really find our way through it.
- Yeah, I don't know about that, but.
(audience laughing)
- I think so.
- I wouldn't say, we all need it,
I mean, it's just a little podcast,
but no, what's nice is that,
I mean, for me,
it has made me feel less alone
in this kind of bizarre world of grief
to realize that I'm on this road
that everybody will be on at some point.
And generations of people
have been here before.
You know, we all,
I remember at Yale, and
it's a perfect example,
anybody's who's an undergraduate here,
you all live in rooms of dead people,
you all live in the rooms
of generations of people
who have been in those rooms before.
And we all think, Robert Henline said,
every generation thinks they invented sex
and every generation is wrong.
You know, we all think we're the first
to like have these
experiences that we're having
and to be facing the issues we're facing.
And as one ages, you start
to realize like, I mean,
and it's an obvious thing,
but there are, everybody,
there's not anything you are
going through in your life
that has not already been gone through
by generations of people before you.
And I take great comfort in that.
Like, it literally helps
me when I'm in a situation
where I feel completely overwhelmed
or like my career is about to be ruined
or my life is about to be
destroyed or whatever it is,
and realize like somebody has
been in this situation before
and there's a way out of it
and things will take their course
and grief is the same way.
You know, there's not any
permutation of my grief
that is original or different,
and yet it feels that way to me,
and I feel completely alone in it,
but realizing that,
realizing all these people
who have been here before
is going through the same things.
I follow on Instagram, the AIDS Memorial.
And to me, it's the most
incredible thing on Instagram
and it's just photographs
of people have died,
put up by their loved ones
with little stories about them.
And I see myself in that
page, every couple of days.
I'm like, that's me, or
that's my friend, Joe,
or whatever it is.
And it's just these generations of people
who are no longer here,
but who went through the exact same stuff
and I find great comfort in that.
Maybe I'm just weird.
- No, no, no.
I will say that for people
who are not quite prepared
to be part of that conversation,
it is quite an emotional
experience, I will say.
Like, I clicked on it just to
see what you were doing and-
- No, no, it'll like stop
you dead in your tracks.
- I will stop you dead in your tracks.
- And like make you weak.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, but I like, there's
nothing wrong with that.
Like, for me-
- No, I think it's so needed.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I think, we're so in this space
of we just have to keep going.
We don't have time.
- Yeah.
- But I think you're telling
us, we should make time.
It's very important.
- Yeah, I mean.
- Grief is not something to-
- Yeah, look, I wasn't
able to talk about loss
for my entire life.
And my brother died
right before senior year,
and I mean, I was
stunned and completely...
Senior year, I was like, I
don't know what I'm doing.
I didn't apply for any jobs.
Like, I graduated.
I had no idea what was gonna happen,
what I was gonna do.
So yeah, I think,
yeah, I don't know.
I certainly would've benefited from,
I wish I had been able to talk about it.
It's not that I didn't know I should,
I certainly knew I should,
and, but yeah, I didn't.
- So maybe this is not
the best place to end,
but I do realize that-
(Anderson and Mary laughing)
- We're really bringing it down here.
- No, I'm hoping the students
will bring us back up.
We're in the portion, I'm
just mindful of the show.
- Sure, yeah.
- We do need to get to our Q&A.
And we did have five students
who had submitted questions that we are,
I think we have time for.
So if the five students
could sort of stand up
and raise their hands so that our...
Excellent, you're all very
close together, kind of.
Megha is all the way out there.
- This is really like the honor system.
I thought like 20 other
people would be like,
oh yeah, I'm one of the. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
- This is what happens
when you're in a college
where the head of college
knows who everybody is.
(Anderson, audience laughing)
- Nobody's trying to fake it out.
- Smart.
- But yes, we can go in this direction.
Megha, you wanna be first?
Go for it.
- [Megha] Hi, thank you so much
for being here with us today.
- Hey!
- [Megha] This feels like really unreal
to just be able to talk to you.
- Me too.
(Mary, audience laughing)
- My name's Megha Joshi.
I'm a senior in Timothy Dwight College.
And I was wondering,
how do you feel that large
news networks such as CNN
affect the polarization of America?
And what do you do in your
profession specifically
to try and minimize it?
- Yeah, look, I think,
we live in an incredibly
polarized society.
I think it's been polarized
for a very long time,
certainly, any reading
of history shows that.
And our media has also,
if you look at, Alexander
Hamilton started the New York Post
in order to get his point across.
I think it's difficult,
I think it's something,
it's certainly something I
think about all the time.
It's something I worry about all the time,
and I know everybody in
my orbit who I work with,
it's a great concern as well.
You know, I try not to,
I'm not interested in
being a liberal newscast
or a conservative newscast.
I don't watch partisan newscast like that.
I'm not interested in what
some overpaid anchor thinks
about what candidate they support
or what policy they like.
Like, I'm not interested in that.
I think our viewers, you know,
should make up their
own minds about stuff.
I believe in facts,
and I believe in presenting
people with facts
and talking to people from
different walks of life
and different political positions
and letting viewers make up their mind.
I do think in an age
where, when people lie,
I think it's the job of
journalists to point that out,
that they are lying.
That can also, at times,
many people think they are doing that,
and that can be very
partisan in some ways,
if you believe,
if you are seeing things
through a certain ideological prism,
and you are confronting
people based on your prism,
and you think you're doing
it because it's true,
and what they're saying is false,
then that can be partisan.
So I think these are all things
you have to be constantly conscious of
and constantly concerned about bias,
and bias in many different forms,
not just political bias, but economic.
The lens through which we see,
everybody sees things through a lens,
and that lens is influenced by geography
of where you're from,
the background you have,
the political beliefs
you have, whatever it is.
There are many kinds of biases.
And I think it's important
to be aware of all of them.
I do think we are living in an age
where there's so much information
and you know, when I was growing up,
it was three broadcast news channels,
and it was ABC, CBS, and NBC,
and Walter Cronkite,
and I don't know who else
was on the other ones.
Everyone watched Walter
Cronkite or Roger Mudd,
I guess, for a while, was on NBC.
And you know, people now,
a lot of people from
my generation and older
look back at that and think,
oh, that was the golden age of news.
Like, we trusted those people.
Those people were good, we trusted them.
But if you actually look back,
like the original newscasts
were 18 minutes long.
And so, that's what people,
people thought they were getting,
in 18 minutes, they
thought they were getting
everything they needed to know.
That's the way it was,
was Walter Cronkite's tagline.
And I have great respect for him.
I think he was an amazing person.
But the newsrooms were all white,
they were all male,
all generally New York, Washington.
There weren't people of color, gay people.
I mean, it was a very
small lens that you were
seeing things through.
And I think it's easy to look for people,
of a certain generation,
to look back on that
and think, oh, that was a time
where you could really
trust what you were seeing.
I actually think we're living
in this extraordinary time
of information where we
all have, in this room,
and on our phones,
access to more information than anybody
in the history of the world
has ever had access to.
And I think that's an amazing thing.
I think it's also overwhelming.
I think it contributes to this feeling
that the world is just
getting worse and worse
and like things are so out of control.
I actually think that
the opposite is true.
I think the world is better
than it's ever been before.
And I think if you look at the data,
just about every metric,
your life is way better than anybody
who's ever lived on the planet.
And your future, I mean, obviously,
there's tremendous climate change,
all sorts of things to be concerned about.
But literacy rates, life expectancy,
I mean, by just about every metric,
life is better than it's ever been
and it's only getting better.
So it's a long way of answering.
I think it's a real issue.
I try not to contribute to polarization.
I try not to demonize
people, as Jimmy was saying.
I try not to fall into this
sort of left right thing.
I try to talk to people
from different backgrounds
and understand where they're coming from
and present that to viewers.
That's what I believe in.
- Thank you.
Okay, who?
Come back, pop back up.
Who was...
I guess, Caitlin, you're next.
- Hello.
- Hi.
- [Caitlin] My name is Caitlin.
I'm a sophomore in TD.
- Cool.
- And I was curious,
so you've covered a lifetime of stories,
but is there one story you feel
that you covered that
didn't receive the attention
or the emotional reaction that it merited?
And if so, how did this
experience change your perspective
on our media consumption?
- Hmm.
Yeah, look, I...
Yeah, a lot of the
stuff I'm interested in,
people aren't interested in so I get that.
And that's okay.
You know, people have a lot
going on in their lives,
and so, I will give
you a specific example,
but I don't wanna sound
like I'm pontificating like,
oh, if only people will
listen to me talk about this,
everything will be fine.
People are busy, they have lives going on.
I totally get that.
And everybody has a right to think about
what they feel is important
and find that information out.
And I'm glad we live in an
age where we can find out
whatever information you wanna
find out, you can find out.
You know, the things that interest me,
I'm drawn to places
that a lot of people
don't pay attention to.
I'm drawn to Democratic Republic of Congo.
I will come back to.
I am fascinated by that country.
I'm fascinated.
There's a tremendous, yeah.
I mean, violence in Eastern
Democratic Republic of Congo
is something I'm very interested in.
And some of the most extraordinary people
I've ever talked have been,
I talked to a woman
named Angela who was...
She was brutally assaulted in her village
by government forces who
came into the village.
She was sexually assaulted
by a number of people.
They tried to get her
brother involved in it.
He resisted, so they slit
his throat in front of her.
They threw one of her children on a fire.
Then after they left,
her husband came back and
kicked her out of the village
because he was afraid
she was HIV positive.
And so, when I met her,
she was living in another
village with her children.
Her child who was thrown
on the fire survived.
And she was waking up every
day and trying to find work,
and she was living and surviving.
And so, that's somebody like
I think about all the time.
Yeah, I wish I could have
done more for that person
in her life to change her life,
and also to tell her story
in a way that more people
would see and watch.
But in all honesty, she
didn't speak English.
And that's difficult for some viewers.
And it's a tough story
and it's easy to turn the channel on,
and I totally understand
that, and I get that.
But for me, I think that's when I,
it's weird to even bring those things up,
but when you're trying to
tell somebody's stories,
these are all things
you have to think about
in terms of how you present the story
and what is the best way
to get that person's story
to an audience.
And hopefully people see it
and want to help the
organization who is helping her,
which is how I found her.
And so,
yeah, I think that's...
There's so many stories
we don't pay attention to that I wish,
there's a lot of
organizations that I work with
after doing stories on them
because I think they're doing great work
and I want to continue that work.
So, yeah, I dunno if that
answers your question, but.
- Hi, Anderson.
- Hey.
- [Arlene] (nervously
laughs) Thank you so much
for being here with us today.
My name's Arlene, and
I'm a sophomore in TD.
And my question is, as
a television journalist,
what has been the biggest
challenge you have faced on CNN
and how did you navigate it
in order to continue
reporting to all the people watching you?
- Hmm.
What's been the biggest challenge?
Hmm, I mean, there's a lot.
There's personal, like handling
stress, things like that.
But I guess more,
look, I think certainly in
the last administration,
it was a challenging
environment and continues to be,
but certainly last administration
was a challenging environment
to be targeted by the
president of the United States,
to have the company I worked for
targeted by the president
of the United States.
And two, it's been an
interesting thing to see
the kind of techniques now being used
by people in public life,
in political life,
to not answer questions
or to just only speak to outlets
that they feel represent
their ideological slant.
And I think as reporters, it's been,
I've worked overseas in regimes
where truth is
not something that you get...
How can I say this?
You know, which are not truthful.
And it's difficult to figure out
how to work in those environments,
how to respond in a way that doesn't,
it's easier to overreact
and it's easier to kind of,
yeah, I'll just say it
was just a difficult time.
To me, personally, that was
the hardest thing, to not,
you know, 'cause I don't want
to express personal opinions.
I'm not interested in being somebody
who wears their opinion on their sleeve
and tries to force it on viewers.
I do believe in listening to other people
and being prepared for interviews
so that you can factually
push back on somebody.
But I don't argue with
people over their politics.
Good people can see
things in different ways.
And there can be some truth on both sides,
but there are facts and I try to stick to,
if I'm in a contentious
interview with somebody,
I try to stick to facts
and what is factually correct
and what they've said that
is not factually correct.
And to me, that's the ground I like
to try to confront somebody on.
- [Carlos] Hello, Mr. Cooper.
I'm Carlos, you kind of just
answered a bit of my question,
but I just wanted to ask like,
how do you separate your
own feelings and opinions
from all the things that you cover?
And I know you just said
you don't like to share your opinion,
but do you think there's like value
in putting your opinion out there
and being honest with the
public of what you think?
- Right.
So...
I don't, look, we live in an age
where everybody is
expressing their opinion.
And I think that's great.
I think it's great but I do
think that there's a role,
you know?
I don't think I'm best at,
like, I don't, yeah.
I don't believe in getting up every night
and expressing my opinion on issues
which affect people's lives
that I may not understand
how somebody with lived
experience sees something
or has experienced something.
And so, I'm not egotistical
enough to believe that,
I'm egotistical but,
I'm egotistical enough to be on TV
but not enough to believe
that I know everything
or that I'm right.
And so, I very much
view myself as learning,
just as our viewers are learning.
And I am generally asking questions
that I'm actually interested
in hearing the answers to.
I'm not interviewing people
who I know reflect a certain,
you know, echo chamber,
that they're gonna give
me a political answer
that is gonna please me
so that my viewers will
only be exposed to some
pleasing point of view.
I believe in being honest
in all things I do,
but it doesn't necessarily mean
that I have to announce ahead of time,
everything I believe in.
I think you can,
if you're focused on facts,
if you're focused on a
world of what is true
and what is not true,
as opposed to shades of gray and opinion,
for me, that's where I, frankly,
I think there's not
enough people doing that.
And so, that is where
I choose to focus on.
Yeah, I dunno if that
answers your question, but.
- Hi Anderson, thank you.
- Hey.
- [Quinn] I'm Quinn, I'm a freshman in TD.
In the past five years,
there's been a pretty sharp increase
in the amount of
misinformation and false news
that's circulated on the
internet and other sources.
And this has led to a
pretty large social shift
in terms of how American,
the American public
views news organizations
with a large portion of the population
solely viewing those outlets
that align with their opinions
and decrying others as fake news.
And with this in mind,
how can news organizations and journalists
individually work to combat this problem
and reinstall trust in the news?
- Hmm, look, I think,
I'll speak for myself.
I think it's important
to do the best you can
and to not be a jerk
and to not get things wrong
and to not give into your biases
and to think about all these things
and to spend a lot of
time worrying about it
and thinking about it.
And I know I do and I know
the people around me do.
I can't speak,
I don't know about some
of these other folks
in other channels and stuff.
You know, it's fascinating
to see the Dominion lawsuit
that's going forward.
I don't know how closely
you've been following this,
but to see sort of the text exchanges
between other anchors and other network,
concerned about the stock
price of the parent company,
I don't know what my parent company,
I'm not even sure who my
parent company is these days.
(Mary, audience laughing)
But like, I don't know
what the stock price is.
It would never even occur to me to like,
why would I care?
And I'm sure my corporate
overlords, whoever they are,
would probably not like that,
but that's just not my job.
And so that was sort of,
I'm not gonna say it surprised me
'cause I know the people involved
and that doesn't surprise me.
But I think it's important
that you have personal standards
and personal things that you personally,
what is right and what is
wrong and what your job is.
You know, I know what my job is.
My job is not to pontificate every night
about what I think and
that's not why I'm there.
I'm there 'cause I've spent a lifetime
of telling other people's stories
and going to places and seeing things
and wanting to bring
viewers to those places
so that they can walk in
somebody else's shoes.
And so, that's the only thing
I add to this conversation
and to add to the table.
There's a lot of people
who do that other stuff
really, really well.
If you want like really smart
liberal people doing that
and if you want really smart
conservative people doing that,
they're out there and they have networks
that are doing really well.
It's just not what I,
I'm just not that way personally
and it just doesn't interest me.
So my interest is,
yeah, in just trying to
understand what is going on
and trying to do it in a way that's human
and not left or right, but
sort of center, I guess.
It doesn't necessarily fit
with the times sometimes,
but to me, that's what
I can do to try to help,
to try to help on the polarization,
to try to help on bias and misinformation.
It's important that like
facts actually matter
and there are things which are true
and there are things which are not true.
And we can actually go and
see the things which are true
and we can tell you about
the things that are true
and we can show you the
things that are not true.
You know, I've interviewed people
who believe I drink the blood of children
and I am secretly a lizard.
(Mary, audience laughing)
And the former president
of the United States
is catering to those people like that.
They're all still out there
and I mean, they literally believe
I drink the blood of
children and, you know,
I don't know what to
do with that, you know?
(audience laughing)
So, yeah.
You know, we live in a time,
it's interesting to me
that the more information
we have access to,
the more this has bubbled up
and the more this
disinformation has spread.
People can find out what is true.
You know, people believe that
Joe Biden is a sock puppet.
It's the same people who
believe I'm a lizard person.
(Mary laughs)
So it's, yeah.
I feel like I can do what I can do
and I just don't, it's easy to get sucked
into all that other stuff
because there's a market incentive clearly
for these other networks to do that.
But it is just not something
that I personally am interested in so,
or believe in.
- So we're not gonna leave it there.
- Okay.
- That would not be okay.
- So why don't we end by asking
what are your future projects?
So you have the Astor book
that's gonna finish out
and what else?
- Are you saying, I need another project?
Is this-
(Mary, audience laughing)
You're adding to my stress here.
- Okay, let me help.
- So no, so look, so I
work, yeah, I do CNN.
I do 10 stories a year for 60 Minutes.
And so, yeah, to me,
60 Minutes is sort of,
a show I've grown up watching
and yeah, I don't know what.
I guess I'm doing another
season of the podcast
and I don't know, I hate,
I sound like I'm pitching products.
I don't like, I don't know, I do stuff.
I don't really know
where my career's going.
I don't know what comes down the pike.
But, yeah.
What I like is being able to just
to work in all these different realms
and thankfully, I'm in a place
where I can do the show on CNN,
I can do 60 Minutes
and I was just in Cambodia for 60 Minutes
for a week on a project,
an investigative project I'm working on.
I just interviewed Rick Rubin,
this really interesting music producer
who's just about every artist
you know, has worked with him.
So I like dropping in on people's,
very different than I would cover on CNN,
but it's interesting to talk
to creative people and yeah,
and work with them.
- On those lines, am I correct
that the Vanderbilt book
is gonna be becoming a television
mini-series or something?
- Yeah, I did.
Yeah, wow, you've done your research.
(Mary, audience laughing)
Yeah, I guess Amazon has picked it up for,
to at least see a pilot
for a possible like dramatic series on it.
Yeah, we'll see.
- So it will be better than
the one that you critiqued
in your book with Angela Lansbury?
- Oh, yeah, so when I was a kid,
so my mom was involved
with this custody battle
when she was 10-years-old.
She was taken away.
It was at the height of the depression.
My mom was, it's so weird and
complicated to even go into.
But basically, my mom's mom
and my mom's great aunt,
Gertrude Vanderbilt Whitney,
who created the Whitney Museum,
they sued for custody over
my 10-year-old mother.
Neither of them really knew my mom,
including her own mother.
But they both sued for custody
and it was called, at the
time, the trial of the century.
It was these two well-known women
fighting for custody of this
very rich 10-year-old girl
who they called little Gloria.
And the country was divided on it.
Hundreds of people would show
up to the court every day.
It went on for months.
My mom, ultimately, was taken
away from her own mother,
sent to live with Gertrude
Vanderbilt Whitney
'cause she was the rich one.
And my mother was raised by this aunt
who she didn't even know
and how do we even get on this topic?
- Because it's gonna become
a dramatized TV series.
- Yeah, but I don't know
why I brought up that.
(Mary, audience laughing)
Oh no, you brought up the
Angela Lansbury thing.
- Angela Lansbury.
- Anyway.
- Yes. Yes.
- My mom never talked
about this experience
she had as a kid when I was a kid,
so I didn't really know anything about it.
And then one day, some lady wrote a book
about the custody battle,
Barbara Goldsmith,
and it became a made for TV miniseries
with Angela Lansbury.
And my mom went ballistic
'cause my mom had never talked about this.
And it was like deeply personal to her
and all of a sudden,
it's a made for TV movie.
So it was really fun the week
that, that TV series was on
to be in my house 'cause
my mom was very upset.
So yes, and it's terrible.
I never saw it until I
wrote the Vanderbilt book
and I finally saw it
and yeah, it's really, it's really awful.
- You're very funny
when you talk about it.
- It's an amazing story,
but it was done very badly.
But yeah, so anyway.
- And it will be much,
much better than that.
- It will be much, much better than that.
How many of you are undergraduates here?
(audience members cheering)
- Wow.
- And are you excited?
Are you optimistic about the world?
- Yeah!
- Yay!
(audience cheers, murmurs)
- I love...
You said that, you did
that the most sarcastically
of anybody I've ever,
you were like, yeah, ah huh.
(Mary, audience laughing)
That's such a Yale thing.
Like yeah, you're optimistic, but yeah,
it's just sarcastically so.
I get it.
- Some things don't change.
- Some things don't change, yeah.
Well, yeah, I just think, I just remember,
I just remember being at Yale
and being like scared of what was to come
and wishing I had a plan
and wishing things were clearer.
And now, and all the
things that I cared about
at Yale at the time,
I didn't really care
so much about classes.
I was a coxswain on a crew team.
I thought that, to me that
was, I was obsessed with it.
Looking back, I'm like,
I don't know why I was so
obsessed with that, but I was,
and all the things now
that I look back fondly on
are not the things I
thought I would remember
and the things I thought
I would care about.
All the things now,
it's like little moments
that I experience with
friends and people on the team
and just these little moments
that were meaningless at the time.
But those are the things,
like, I was on this crew team
and I don't remember how we did.
We apparently did very
well, I've been told.
But like, I don't remember the races,
I don't remember where we were
in the national championships
and stuff like that.
But I remember like riding on
the bus out to the boathouse.
I remember the creek on the
stairs in the boathouse.
Just these little things.
I remember hanging out in Durfee
with all my other loser roommates and me.
(Mary, audience laughing)
And all that stuff has taken
on a much greater import
than when I was actually going through it.
And so, I guess I would just say,
especially the freshman,
is just to enjoy the
experience you're having
'cause what you're gonna
remember of it is so different
than what you think you're
gonna remember of it.
And you're gonna hear like,
and it won't have any reality for you
until you're an old person like me
and coming back and you'll be like,
oh, I don't remember this,
but I remember the ice
cream at Durfee Hall
or whatever it was.
So anyway, that's it.
- All right.
- That's all I got.
- All right, please join me
in thanking Anderson Cooper.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)